[Música]
sean bienvenidos a cinco minutos
o'connor y roberto de nyse periodista e
investigador en armando punto info la
conversación de hoy es sobre las
investigaciones en relación con el
empresario colombiano álex a saab
presunto testaferro del presidente de
venezuela nicolás maduro sabe está
detenido desde junio pasado por órdenes
de interpol y el y el gobierno
venezolano luchan para impedir su
extradición a eeuu que ya fue aprobada
por una corte local de nyse gracias por
acompañarnos de bienvenido france24 y
recuerda nos primero para la audiencia
que se conecta principalmente en américa
latina' quién es este personaje cuya
detención ha hecho que el gobierno de
nicolás maduro esté usando todos los
recursos a su alcance para impedir que
sea extraditado a eeuu
alexa es un empresario colombiano de
barranquilla que hace muchos años en el
2011 comenzó su carrera de negocios en
venezuela estaba vivo todavía el
presidente chávez pero es con la llegada
de nicolás maduro a la presidencia a
partir de abril de 2013 donde el primero
se convierte en una especie de gran
contratista del propio nicolás maduro y
de su gobierno pero con el paso de los
años va ganando más digamos protagonismo
y empieza a ser una especie de asesor en
la sombra y el responsable de negros
negocios claves y estratégicos para el
chavismo con sus aliados en rusia irán y
turquía más recientemente
mire porque denis el interés de eeuu en
la figura de esa dada su relación de
larga data con venezuela qué información
podría presentar
alexa se le abre a mediados de 2019 una
acusación por lavado de dinero entre
otros delitos en una corte de florida
esa acusación se está relacionada con
uno de sus negocios en venezuela que era
la construcción de casas prefabricadas
a partir de allí y yo creo que es la
seña clave de que eeuu comprueba la
dimensión de este personaje de esa
acusación
también fue incluido en la lista de la
ofac del departamento del tesoro y allí
se detallan toda una serie de conexiones
de supuestos pagos de coimas por recibir
contratos al entorno más cercano de
nicolás maduro y como decía yo creo que
es lo que está aún no está convencido de
que se trata de un personaje clave y
estratégico para nicolás maduro
como él como persona pero también para
el régimen chavista desde el punto de
vista financiero estaba presentado ya la
última apelación en la cual tiene
derecho ante la justicia de cabo verde
que insiste en extraditarlo usted cree
que finalmente terminará en eeuu o los
recursos de sus abogados podrían tener
éxito todo el proceso legal que se ha
seguido en cabo verde desde junio del
año pasado cuando fue detenido parecen
indicar que alexa va a ser extraditado a
los estados unidos primero un tribunal
de apelaciones dijo que había méritos
para la extradición más recientemente
vimos que la corte suprema de cabo verde
confirmó que había méritos para la
extradición resta una apelación de parte
de la defensa dirigida por el ex juez
español baltasar garzón ante el tribunal
constitucional de cabo verde pero todo
parece indicar que se trata de un
proceso digamos para demorar lo más
posible su inminente extradición ya nos
vamos quedando sin tiempo pero quería
preguntarle si eventualmente esa vez
podría también proveer información sobre
temas de corrupción en colombia
y también porque pasa con alexa up que
es una especie de personaje como decía
bisagra del chavismo con con distintos
aliados por la importancia de los
negocios que ha manejado manejado
petróleo ha manejado las deportaciones
del oro venezolano pero también es un
personaje con unas relaciones políticas
muy poderosas en colombia varias
personas él es amigo personal por
ejemplo de la ex senadora colombiana
piedad córdoba uno de sus abogados en
colombia ha sido el señor abelardo de la
espriella que es abogado entre otras
entre otras figuras en colombia en
algunos casos del ex presidente el ex
presidente álvaro uribe de manera pues
que alexa tiene muchas conexiones
políticas no solo en colombia también
con funcionarios políticos de la isla de
antigua y barbuda él hasta hace años
tuvo una especie también de pasaporte
diplomático de allí y así sin lugar a
dudas no sólo es un caso que afecta a
venezuela es un caso que puede afectar a
otros estamentos políticos y
empresariales de la región
roberto denis periodista e investigador
en armando puntoinfo gracias a ustedes
por estar con nosotros y a nuestra
audiencia continúen en francia
[Música]